and the sentence is done elaine maxwell
will be in prison for 20 years
apparently it's like a low security
thing and uh going to prison for
trafficking children to no one
apparently to not a single person but uh
apparently still trafficking trafficking
them so uh you have to wonder who we'd
love to see the uh the list of clients
but for some reason they're not telling
us
also maxwell was placed on um
suicide watch sparking many memes so i
guess we're going to talk about all of
that and we also have news pertaining to
democrats because this is hilarious for
the past couple of weeks it's been
reported that democrats have been
funding trump supporting republican
candidates in republican primaries
under the the idea that it's going to
help them win
i don't understand what they they think
like well these these pro-life
republicans can't possibly win a general
election meanwhile people are vowing to
vote against the democrats regardless of
who they're voting for because i don't
know the economy is in shambles and the
democrats have embraced insane cultural
issues those tend to be in in the polls
people saying like hey i don't like that
like you look at virginia with yunkan
and now you look at the five dollar gas
all they're doing is propping up trump
and then holding january 6 hearings
where they complain about trump and
blame
the thing they're funding for destroying
this country it's beautiful and then the
last uh we got a bunch of other stories
but one is really really funny
apparently a former white house staffer
is claiming trump lunged at the steering
wheel and tried to like commandeer a
vehicle
through the security barrier from the
back seat to the front it makes no sense
the story makes no sense trump came out
and said it's nonsense and apparently we
have a statement to journalists that
they're corroborating secret service
agents who said this lady at the january
6 hearing is making it up
can't say i'm surprised ladies and
gentlemen before we get started with all
of that news head over to timcast.com
and become a member to help support our
work as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 p.m members only
it is uncensored tim cast after dark we
swear a lot and we tell naughty jokes so
you'll definitely want to check that out
and uh don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel and um
share the show if you really do like it
follow me at tim cast and follow the
show at tim cast irl joining us today to
talk about all of this is quite frankly
hey
tim who are you i come
in peace
on behalf of my tribe and so thank you
everybody for having me here that's just
one tim you know the last time i saw you
it was a day before you went to malmo oh
wow it was the lay before a while ago
the other thing there too is
tim went to a local diner with me after
one of those shows that we were hanging
out one night and they you've become
very very very famous since then you've
become they've actually bronzed the seat
that you sat in that night
yes i know it's diana ross and tim poole
when it comes to greenwich connecticut
there's nobody bigger
so so what do you do oh i'm just a talk
show host from new york
current events history hidden history
actually most hidden uh history is
hidden these days you know what i mean
yeah i i don't know i can't tell because
i can't see it but i think you might be
on to something well either way that's
what it is that the human condition we
just like talking about things that uh
make us human and and i'm so happy to be
here it's been a wonderful day so far
the drive was beautiful
a lot of trees yeah gorgeous out here
that's cool there's there are modern
rabbits everywhere reminds me of upstate
new york to be honest except we have
wine berries
i never see there's wild chinese
raspberry everywhere
you just like walk up the driveway and
you can fill up your hands with just all
these berries and just eat them and be
full and you're done
now they're not quite uh in bloom yet or
whatever fruiting whatever the word is
but i had a couple today just walking
around i picked them up is it is there
like a limit before the diarrhea sets in
it's like one of those things
well i mean i'm pretty sure if you eat
anything to excess probably but uh
they're delicious and amazing and we
made ice cream with them last year yeah
sheamus i can see he's jealous i
remember that no i think i was here when
you guys made uh i remember you making
something out of them we want to make
wine wine wine wine wine berry wine wine
berry wine wine wine
i don't actually think we can do it but
i don't know
not without a liquor license sir that's
right i don't know a report west
virginia if you're gonna do that you
better stomp the berries with your bare
feet like they do in the old country
stomp the berries do it wine
sheamus who are you well
that's a tough question it keeps me up
most nights and i'm not entirely sure
but i can tell you what i do i create
cartoons at a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we just released one today
i think you guys are really gonna enjoy
it it's been a hit the fans are loving
it it's how
lefties debate it's a short 30-second
one that i think will enrich your life
we also launched a website and on that
website
we will be posting every week either a
new cartoon that week that is just
exclusive for patrons or like a a much
extended cut of the current video like
several minutes longer so go over there
freedomtunes.com become a member five
bucks a month help us get free from the
establishment in big tech well hello
everyone ian crossland here and i'm
actually thinking about what you said
frank about hidden history because when
someone's telling his story
uh it's really not only is it about the
things he tells you but also about the
things he didn't tell you and that's
what they call reading between the lines
or telling her story yeah right
are you changing language as we speak i
just think it's confusing that it
bothers you that he would say herstory
let's use roman numerals in our
constitution i was reading through the
constitution last night and the roman
numerals were making me ill all right we
gotta just change that
how dare they look i mean it's hard
arabic numerals only okay you know oh
let's i'll talk about this on the show
well let me get this out of the way
really quick you know the white house is
like those white roman pillars i
realized the romans painted their white
marble and the paint just wore off
absolutely but the americans are like
dude let's do white buildings everywhere
it's like we did paint those as well and
the paint wore off okay no i'm kidding
so let's paint the white house is what i
don't know we had to paint the white
house
after it was burned down in the 1812 war
what's a good color purple red for the
white house
you know those wraps where it like it
changes color depending on how you look
at it holographic holographic wraps like
the holographic you know what i think we
should do i don't know why we didn't do
this after we got burnt down the first
time but like painted into the landscape
camouflage don't let anyone know where
it is just all sky blue exactly exactly
there you go anyway it's been a good
conversation already i was gonna say
that most of history is hidden and i see
people commenting on the news nowadays
and they're like well if this is what
they're covering up this makes me wonder
about all the rest of history so i think
that yeah probably all history is to
some degree very much hidden anyway i'm
very excited for tonight's conversation
looking forward to your perspective for
sure here's the big news ladies and
gentlemen maxwell sentenced to 20 years
in prison for what as epstein case nears
its end maxwell the former socialite who
conspired with epstein to exploit
underage girls was sentenced to 20 years
in prison on tuesday by a judge who said
she played a pivotal role in
facilitating a horrific scheme that
spanned continents and years maxwell 60
is the daughter of a british media
magnate robert maxwell convicted
december 29th of trafficking and other
counts after a month-long trial at which
the government presented testimony and
other evidence depicting maxwell as a
sophisticated predator who groomed
vulnerable young women and girls as long
as as long as young as 14 years old for
abuse by epstein is that it just epstein
i guess
people gracious people were flying on
his plane with him and going to his
island but
it was just a coincidence
so so uh maxwell's client list is
published it's epstein that's it we're
done everybody you can go home that's
all it was nothing to see here
this article frames it as as it comes to
an end as the epstein case comes to an
end we're now laying the hammer down as
hard as we can on gi lane to show that
it's definitely done don't ask questions
well my question is do you think it's
really her do you think it's really her
like you think actually like and
actually in jail i thought that the
trial itself was such a farce that i
said to myself i wouldn't be surprised
if they say guilty they bring her out
the back door send her to the bahamas
and then just send somebody to jail no
like face off like they take elaine and
some other woman and then like sedate
her and they cut their faces off and
switch them and this other woman is like
i'm not elaine i'm innocent they're like
quiet you crazy good baby no it's her
dude i mean that's what she said in
court she used the old face-off defense
and just like come on we've heard that
too you know how many faces i've had the
old face-off defense she has like actual
scars going around her face and she's
just and they're just like looks fine
no i look i'd love to believe that like
people believed that epstein wasn't
really epstein
and like they showed there's like a
picture of him being taken out of the
prison and they're like it looks
slightly different and i'm like yeah
he's dead yeah yeah like his muscles
have like
probably he voided his balls like he's
really awful stuff and i'm just like you
know i'd love to believe that they
smuggled these people out just because
it makes you think that you're actually
fighting some grand fight but come on
the reality is these people got busted
the feds backed off and we're letting
them do their thing who knows why
probably blackmail or something and then
we had a series of events we had
reporting from mike cernovich we had a
reporting reporting i think from the
miami herald we had reporting for
project veritas that all helped push
this into the in front and center with
maxwell and epstein and they got caught
and they got thrown to the bus and then
bill gates gets asked to ask uh asked
about it that was funny it's like oh
what does it matter he's dead now he's
like yikes dude you're on his plane yeah
and if they start naming names what'll
happen is they'll name one and then that
person is gonna start naming a bunch of
other ones and then another and then the
whole web starts together he just wasn't
important enough i i mean i don't i
don't i never really read into any of
the it's not really him look at the ear
all that stuff he just wasn't important
enough
no yeah he wasn't that's that's somebody
that's going to get flushed at some
point especially when you're when you're
in and out of the news and you just
cannot stop uh he was useful at a time
against again for somebody higher up the
chain and uh and there's a lot more
questions about how high the chain goes
so you guys ready this is a story
actually from a couple days ago cnn
reporting geelane maxwell is on suicide
watch but isn't suicidal may need to
postpone sentencing well they didn't
postpone sentence postpone sentencing
um
but they are putting her on suicide
watch even though she isn't and uh
everybody started posting memes
because uh surprise surprise they're
like oh no she's gonna she's gonna hurt
herself and then what happened suicide
watch but not suicidal does that just
mean they're afraid someone's going to
fake her suicide
i don't know
that's very blatant it's like a weird
thing i know
they're like she's on the watch she
doesn't want to do it
now that which is why she's on watch
she's like guys i really don't want to
commit suicide please watch me like
please look at she's not suicidal now
but she may be later yeah or let's be
real this may not be as an affair as it
sounds it may be
that there's a fear in the federal
government that someone powerful is
going to try and you know flush her out
what is it shake her loose her mortal
coil and so they put her on watch
because there's no other watch that
there can be hey guys just please make
sure that the guards got a full night
rest the night before this time you know
is there is there a homicide watch for
for uh inmates
no because no one would ever kill an
inmate it's like unconscionable so they
don't even call it no but you're you're
by yourself right
you're you're you're in solitary you're
in a jso by yourself there's not going
to be homicide watch they're not going
to be like because there's no one to
actually perceivably kill you yeah so
the only thing they could do to make
sure you live is put you on suicide
watch even if you're not and then they
say she's not suicidal they're basically
saying cena's saying we think somebody
wants to kill her
yeah that's what it sounds like i i mean
technically anyone could could be a
victim of homicide even if they were a
prisoner because like the guards could
be paid off to do it people on the guard
you know the prison owners could be do
it what if like with epstein it was this
crazy scenario because like weren't the
guards sleeping yeah guards are sleeping
make sure they're broke the cameras were
broke uh it's just
then who knows that things just happen
look i've seen i've seen x-men where you
know you have mystique
and she drugs that guy
and she injects him full of iron and
then magneto escapes so you know i'm
just saying maybe somebody drugged the
guards and then had magnetic powers to
disable the camera i remember that that
proves it i mean it's it's more
believable than the official explanation
shockingly yes
that's why i don't that's why i don't
look at this i say how how does it end
with her because she was definitely his
handler
so how does it end with her oh i i
thought for sure though there was a game
there was definitely a game of chicken
being played between her defense i mean
the whole thing was weird they brought
in the cia memory lawyers and everything
remember three lawyers yeah
there's a certain type of shrink that
comes in to talk about how your memory
was not
really what it is they try to i mean and
then of course after two weeks we got
four months of johnny depp but after two
weeks they say we got to get this over
with there's another wave of covey
coming through new york and i this and
like i said we don't know anything you
know like the johnny depp trial while
while all this is still going on it's
just like i'm imagining
you know there's like a shocking crime
to your left and then a you know police
van opens up and a bunch of clowns come
out and start going like and they're
like dancing around everyone's like oh
hey clowns and they stopped paying
attention to the crazy crime happening
to their left indeed the bigger question
here is sure sure we know
that
you know elaine maxwell
even though we all have our suspicions
about epstein and the media is
desperately trying to be like it's a
conspiracy theory and all that but like
no sane person believes that he took his
own life we know all this
it should probably is gonna something's
gonna happen to her and then the bigger
question is who
who was involved
i think
nobody no yeah no one would you know
called it all right i think it was bill
gates
we know he flew on the plane so until
they prove otherwise it's him that's
fair
i would ask alex acosta
who's that the old trump labor secretary
who was uh who's actually part of this
whole thing when they were wrapping up
um operation leap year that actually put
the the full scope of what epstein was
doing in new mexico and florida new york
the caribbean all that together i would
ask
it was acosta was when he was getting
thrown out of of his office in 2018 or
19 or whatever the hell it was um he was
asked by somebody in the room uh how
to explain exactly who came to him to
stop
the fbi from going forward with this
just the full weight coming down on on
epstein is there somebody coming up if
it was if he was uh involved with
intelligence and he said let's just he
pretty much said let's move away from
that didn't the democrats bring on the
abc news guy who shut down the the
epstein reporting to do the january 6
trial i believe that's because that was
that what it was we need where's luke at
why isn't luke here we need him
because luke knows what's good for him
that's what he said
vanity fair yeah
sheamus you know i gave him a stern
talking to you let's just say
threatened to to bop him i didn't hold
on there were no there's no proof of
that there's no proof of that luke and i
had a conversation and
we came to an understanding i see and
now he's gone
it's pretty florida i think i think i
didn't know if i was gonna meet luke
today i was like oh i'm gonna i might
make me luke oh you owe me at luke i
think he's in new york he's charged a
bullet
um i think that if you look at maria
farmer's settles uh painting she's
basically illustrated all the people she
remembers being involved and i'm not
going to name names because i don't want
to get into that mess messy because you
don't want to be on suicide
it's anecdotal no one knows for sure but
i have a feeling that people like you
know very very high up in government
ex-presidents maybe even did things that
they shouldn't have done with people
that were under the age of 18 and that's
why everything's completely silent
they're like about to sentence max well
and the judge is like do you have
anything to say for yourself before i
issue my sentencing and she goes
just love living life is great i've
never been happier i've grown quite fond
of being alive and i'd like that to be
reflected in these stenographers notes
anyway carry on that was the funniest
part about the whole epstein thing right
before he died uh they're saying we're
putting him on suicide watch i said this
guy is not someone who wants to die he
just upped his bail uh his bail offering
to the court to like 150 million the
week before that's not something that
someone who wants to kill themselves
does that's someone who wants to get the
hell out right um and the camera stopped
working
here here's how we're going to make sure
that nothing happens to elaine all right
tim we're getting involved here we're
going to make elaine city and it's going
to be like chicken city but it's just
going to be cameras all over herself
yeah and if you you donate you know you
we will have gelane parties i mean
actually i don't even want to know that
oh yeah no no no what we do is it's like
a little drop from the yeah
and she can eat it off the ground yeah
exactly like i have no i have no respect
for this woman nothing but disdain and
so exactly and so it'll just be if she
gets food it'll be it'll be like uh
we'll have to make sure the corn chia is
really bad too it'll be like a
for-profit way to ensure that uh you
know she doesn't uh commit suicide did
you see oh are you saying i was gonna
say i think they put her on suicide
watch to keep her from to postpone her
sentencing and i also wanted to say that
mccarthy did point out that the the
ex-abc president who spiked the jeffrey
epstein story was in fact in charge of
the january six hearings it'd be funny
if like cute
once you raise a hundred she's like
imagine her in her jail cell and people
are giving five bucks and like corn
falls on the ground and she's like she's
like i'm not eating off the ground get
out of here and then a hundred dollars
gets reached and then the the guillain
party happens and the lights are flat
horns
spraying corn in her face
so for those that understand the
reference we have a show called chicken
city where you can do all of that for
chickens i love it and when the corn
falls in the ground it's it's actually
like treats and mealworms the chickens
love it and they run and they eat it and
they're all excited i didn't know this
until yesterday okay i didn't know i
didn't know the intro i watched you guys
as much as i can cause you know my show
overlaps my second hour overlaps with
your first hour um
uh but i i was just showed yesterday the
chicken city feed
oh yeah it's nice i didn't second most
profitable show
literally is i remember those chickens i
remember when epstein was in the news
because he had been arrested again and
he was going to trial this before he
killed himself uh and i was
talking with my uncle who was uh you
know a police officer on the south side
of chicago for like 20 or 30 years
so
he had you know a more more less naive
attitude than me let's say and so i was
talking i was like
yeah i'm just i'm excited for this guy
to really go to trial and for some of
these people who were trafficking kids
to get exposed he goes nah he's going to
kill himself he's like come on he's like
he's going to kill himself
they're not going to hurt the guy yeah
he didn't do the air quotes he said it
but i knew what he was saying he's like
he's like they're gonna kill him he's
gonna commit suicide that's it and i was
like
oh you're probably right and then three
or four days later i wake up in the
morning with the notification on my
phone jeffrey epstein has killed himself
i was like oh my god at this point if
they do pull off a face off with
guillain
it would be so that
they could suicide elaine without anyone
realizing it happened because if she
really does take her life
you know it's gonna be just like the
at that point it's a conspiracy theory
that they killed themselves well people
are already saying about saying that
about epstein well the thing is like i
just hope no one comes into her cell
with a noose and says this is mega
country that'd be the worst that would
be the worst i mean look it's do you
remember when jesse was like i'm not
suicidal
he was getting trapped out of the court
dude what that's what i'm just saying
i know it's it could be crazy but
we only get three pictures the same
three pictures of elaine maxwell over
and over again everything else is court
paintings
you just don't know and
the older somebody gets the more they
look like everybody else like when all
the ruth bader ginsburg uh rumors were
going around she literally looks like
larry king i mean you can you can you
start looking like larry king you look
like a coat iraq it's just
i i think anything's ha anything's
possible these days i believe i can
believe anything i mean
they've certainly lost the confidence of
the people
and we've i think for the most part the
people have lost their willingness to
give the benefit of the doubt when
epstein's epstein's cellmate didn't he
like
save him from a suicide attempt or
something like that like what happened
he got assaulted or something right i
thought he was from westchester
yeah yeah as i get attacked by a
cellmate or something like that yeah and
they were like oh no like it's like dude
that guy's trying to come out he's
getting he's getting he's getting
strangled by his cellmate and the girls
are like no epstein you have so much to
live for don't do it no don't do this to
yourself
what all right oh in the early days of
jeff getting or after got arrested i
think that like a couple weeks after he
was arrested a picture came out of him
just looking annihilated like messed up
and he i think he said that they were
trying to poison him did he say that did
that come out that doesn't sound
familiar but it reminds me of uh that
family guy episode where quagmire is
getting strangled by his uh his sister's
husband or whatever and then he like
dies
but like he just
feigns death and then the next scene is
him running over his sister's you know
his brother-in-law and he's like i
strangle myself like that every night
so like i'm just saying like epstein
getting strangled it didn't take the
first time you know like the guy tried
to hurt him and he was like ha
yeah because i have a strong man i have
a strong neck
and then they you know his neck broke is
this so is that what happened right what
was the official narrative that he like
used toilet paper or something like i
don't i don't even know there was
multiple there was multiple breaks too
and they brought it back they brought in
a uh a jfk uh
uh
guy for this right well what was the
guy's name
that did the autopsy
i uh oh that's right i know what you're
talking about i know what you're talking
about hold on let's let's get this
pulled up because i don't want to miss
this refresher but i just want to say
whichever toilet paper he hung himself
with supposedly like that toilet paper
like you should put that in all their
advertisements like this is the toughest
toilet paper uh it was it was a smock or
something or a sheet wasn't it okay so
then apparently he stood they said that
he was kneeling on top the top bunk put
her on his neck and then jumped off and
it's like snapped his neck or something
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you